the moment a rocket barrage from Lebanon
hits the Israeli Border City of
Katona alasam brigades in Lebanon
claimed responsibility for launching 12
missiles two of them inflicting this
damage the escalation on the Lebanese
Israeli front is significant we can see
that uh you know uh who is really
executing all of this it's not only
hisbah we are seeing you know different
Palestinian faction and you know uh
loudly they are saying they are
participating so we are seeing like
little bit of
escalation the most significant incident
two explosive Laden drones hitting an
Israeli Command Center in the disputed
sha Farms an attack claimed by Lebanese
group hisbah the group saying it also
launched 19 simultaneous attacks on
Israeli military positions with guided
missiles and artillery Israel says its
war planes attack targets of hasbullah
in South Lebanon the group announcing at
least five of its Fighters were killed
in
action the increasing intensity on the
Lebanon Israel border comes ahead of a
speech by he's leader Hassan nasah but
not everyone thinks the escalation will
turn into all out War but how concerning
is it that there have been consistent
engagement with Israeli forces obviously
we're concerned about about uh continued
attacks on Israeli forces there uh in
the north as are the Israelis um uh but
I don't believe we've seen any
indication yet specifically that
Hezbollah is is uh ready to go in full
force so we'll see what he has to
say but Rules of Engagement on the
Lebanese front have shifted considerably
over the past few weeks which is
increasing concerns that the conflict
will become a regional one Ali Hashim Al
jaaz nakura South
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer